in this video we're going to talk about
random sampling which we've already
talked about in other videos and we're
going to compare what we already know
about simple random sampling to a new
type of random sampling that we're going
to introduce in this video and that is
systematic
random
sampling so let's look at an example
let's say that there is a concert that
is happening
and we expect approximately 10 000
people to attend the concert
and we want to randomly sample people at
the concert maybe we want to do a study
on how do people get to the concert how
do people
get
to the concert do they drive and park do
they ride with a friend do they take an
uber or a cab of some kind and so we
want to find a
a random sample ideally without bias to
survey people
so there's a couple of ways you could do
it you could try to do a simple
random
sample
and that might be a case of if you could
somehow get the names of all 10 000
people and put them into a big bowl like
this
and then let's say you want to sample
100 people let's say you want to sample
approximately
100
people
you could just mix up all the names
maybe on these little pieces of paper
ten thousand of them and then pull them
out and pull out a random sample of a
hundred of them that would be a simple
random sample
but you could already imagine there
might be some logistic difficulties of
doing this how are you going to get the
10 000 names you're going to write them
on a piece of paper that's going to be a
you'd have to really mix some good so
it's truly random who you're picking out
so are there other ways of doing a
random sample and as you can imagine yes
there are and that's where systematic
random sampling is useful
one way to think about systematic random
sampling is you're going to randomly
sample a subset of the people who are
maybe walking into the concert so let's
say people get to the concert and they
start forming a line to get into the
concert
what you want to do in systematic random
sampling is randomly pick your first
person there's a bunch of ways that you
could do that let's say you have a
random number generator that'll generate
a number from 1 to 100 and that's going
to be the first person you survey if
that random number generator generates a
37 then you're going to start with the
37th person in line
so you pick that first person randomly
you survey them remember our goal is to
sample about a hundred people out of ten
thousand so we wanna roughly sample one
out of every hundred people and so what
you do there is once you have that first
person that you're sampling you then
sample every 100th person after that
that's called sometimes the sample
interval and the reason why 100 people
is because if you sample every 100th
person after that you're going to
roughly get 100 people in your sample
out of a total of 10 000. so this is
going to be after 100 you're going to
sample someone else and then after
another 100 you're going to sample
someone else
now the reason why this is useful is you
could say okay that first person was
random and then every person after that
it doesn't seem like there would be any
bias for why they would be the hundredth
person after that first person you don't
want to just do the first hundred people
because those might be the early birds
the people who maybe disproportionately
went parking or planned early or had
some bias in some way so you do want to
make sure that you're getting you know
both the beginning the middle and the
end of the line which this thing helps
now we have to be careful even
systematic random sampling is not
foolproof there's a situation where
inadvertently even this system has bias
let's say that this is the arena this is
a top view of the arena right over here
and this is the line of people
coming in and this is where you are
standing
and you are counting every hundredth
person but maybe and let's say there's a
tree
right over here and maybe there's a road
i'm making this quite elaborate
so maybe there is a road right over here
and a lot of people maybe all of the
people who are
walking or taking a cab are coming from
this direction and maybe all the people
from the parking lot are coming
from this direction and maybe you have a
police officer right over here who is
doing crowd control who lets 50 people
50 of these people in followed by 50 of
these people in well in that situation
every 100th you might end up just
sampling one side or the other so you
have to make sure that there isn't some
bias that's being introduced into this
line somehow that might distort your
sample